uh this is a tough one I say listening
to these songs knowing these songs both
so well where does inspiration stop and
copying star Jason yeah it's a great
question it's one that's surrounded the
music industry for quite a very long
time ever like ever well so at the end
of the day you know the copyright
statute looks at a couple of different
things and one of which is an extrinsic
test that looks at everything
subjectively and it examines the musical
pieces itself and it makes a
determination as to whether there is
substantial similarity and then on the
flip side there's a Sarika job fit that
there's a subjective test that actually
looks whether a reasonable person would
think this is copying so you have those
two pieces of thought hitting each other
and therefore this this strikes me is
not that similar I mean these songs are
clearly you know there's an influence
but who I mean what musician isn't
influenced by Marvin Gaye's since 1980
you know I mean you can't do our and be
and not know Marvin Gaye's work
especially that great tune yeah
absolutely you know at the at the end of
the day there's a there's a train of
thought here that that an award like
this is actually a big win for music
companies and music publishers who own
you know very large substantial
catalogues and that the value of these
historical pieces of music will go up
but in actuality I think most in the
music business look at this as a
actually a stifling of music evolution
because you know as you said there isn't
really a situation ever in music where a
feeling of an error is is incorporated
into new music and at the end of the day
songwriters hearken back to you know to
their legends to write music and that's
a big part of how art progresses in
early 90s as hip-hop became very
mainstream the the music publishing
business went from licensing songs to
licensing samples and and I wonder if
the evolution of that bit
this and the the sort of codifying of
laws around sampling change the rules of
the road in terms of sort of the
interpretation of music or reasonable
influences well there's a point to be
made there that the the pattern of music
popular music over the last twenty years
plus has used both sampling where the
actual musical recordings used in the
underlying track as well as
interpolations where songwriters utilize
pieces of prior works in their new
derivative works and that has become a
very big pattern over the years you've
seen it you've seen it is you know as
far back as George Harrison and Michael
Bolton as well as a very big case matter
that involved the verb using rolling
stone song in bittersweet symphony and
and in that instance the Rolling Stones
got a hundred percent of the songwriter
royalties so because it was but it was
stolen right it was clearly their tune
that was recorded and uses it as a
background for that too yeah in that
instance that is correct and there was
actually an original license in that in
that case where there was a license a
sampling license but the license was was
they used too much based on what the
license said they were allowed to use
but but to your point the the music
business has definitely evolved to a
case of using prior art very much in
current art and you know obviously
songwriters and music publishers deserve
the right to get paid for their prior
art but at the same time I think that
the courts have to be very careful about
stifling creativity chase a real quick
cage match who you got Marty you got Sir
Robin Thicke and Pharrell on one side
you got Marvin Gaye and the other I love
them all I mean in this instance we see
that we see we see the classics one this
one